si compétences bien là elle depuis le
1er janvier 2016 la loi notre confie de
nouvelles compétences aux régions la
région à la gestion de la mobilité
urbaine sur son territoire pour les
transports en commun la gestion est à la
charge du syndicat de transport
ile-de-france mobilité présidée par le
ou la présidente de région par
convention 1500 lignes de bus 14 métro
dit tramway ou encore treize lignes de
trains et de rer
la région ile de france occupe de 465
lycées publics
elle en assure la construction
l'extension les réparations l'équipement
et le fonctionnement et les régions
doivent aussi définir une stratégie
régionale pour l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche et l'innovation elle la
région est chargé de la politique
d'accès à la formation professionnelle
des jeunes et adultes une offre
territorialisée par bassin d'emploi
s'y ajoutent l'apprentissage l'insertion
des jeunes en difficulté et les
formations en alternance
l'île de france est aussi en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement gestion des déchets des
parcs naturels régionaux plan régional
pour la qualité de l'air elle suit le
sdrif un schéma directeur spécifique
réévalué en 2019
la collectivité doit établir un chemin
régional de développement économique
d'innovation et d'internationalisation
il est défini pour indiquer les
orientations en matière d' aides aux
entreprises à leurs innovations et les
aides à l'investissement immobilier
elle la région assure la gestion des
programmes européens comme le feder et
l'aide entreprises collectivités
associations et milieu éducatif a
sollicité des financements européens
pour leur projet la région partagent
aussi des compétences avec le
département elles sont au nombre de 6 le
tourisme la culture le sport la
promotion des langues régionales
l'éducation populaire ou encore la lutte
contre la fracture numérique